what's popping Kaiju it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is going to be a breakdown of the
first two episodes of the new Apple TV
series Monarch Legacy of monsters and
spoilers for all the monsterverse movies
by the way as this show is part of
legendary pictures overall Cinematic
Universe so we are definitely going to
be touching on some of those movies but
yeah without further Ado let's jump into
it as the show starts we get flashes of
the 1973 footage of Kong's helicopter
attack from the 2017 film Kong skull
Island followed by the return of actor
John Goodman in his role as Monarch
researcher William Randa after his debut
in that very same Kong Skull Island
movie A debut that would also
unfortunately feature his demise at the
mouth of one of skull Island's skull
crawlers so you know that's what he gets
for skipping arm day at the gym and
letting his wife fall down a hole
covered in bugs couldn't be me I love my
wife just kidding I'm not married CU I'm
single forever for those of you who may
not remember Bill Randa was the Monarch
researcher who gathered a team comprised
red of military personnel animal
trackers and photographers and brought
them to Kong's home of Skull Island in
order to confirm the existence of
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms or mutos and potentially
destroy any mutos they find but uh
things quickly headed south and a bunch
of army people died so you know whoops
John Goodman is of course no stranger to
secret monster corporations as he has
famously portrayed a far less
intimidating monster in Pixar's Monsters
Inc in 2001 so it's kind of funny that
he's part of another monster
organization yet again but anyways the
intro continues with Goodman's Bill
Randa leaving a message for an unnamed
recipient while being chased by a giant
ass spider on Skull Island he mentions
that the person that the message was for
would likely not care that he was dead
making me believe that this message
could have been intended for Kurt and
Wyatt Russell's Lee Shaw a man who saw
the woman that he secretly loved get
dropped down a hole due to Bill randa's
Younger self being unable to hold on
however since Bill randa's bag that
throws into the ocean does end up being
found within the office of Kate and
karo's mysterious father there's also
the possibility that the message could
have been for him however William Randa
and Lee Shaw's history during their
younger days definitely leads me to
believe that that video message was in
fact for Shaw then we get a look at the
heavily symbolic opening credit sequence
that firmly captures the overall theme
of dualities of the show a show about
two Randa women from two different time
periods trying to uncover two different
but linked Mysteries Mysteries spanning
two countries involving the mysterious
double life of Kate and karo's father a
theme of dualities that I believe was
chosen to embody the symmetrical design
of the Monarch logo itself with its two
mirrored halves which was an extremely
clever creative decision in my opinion
first we get a symmetrically mirrored
look at the mysterious satellite map
from Hiroshi randa's office a map that
seemingly appears to contain the
radioactive Trail of the flying mudo
that bill and KO track when they first
meet in episode 2 after this we see
symmetrical dualities represented in the
form of past and present classified
Monarch documents new and old Monarch
uniforms opposing photographs of Hiroshi
randa's two families two pictures of
Hiroshi Randa to represent his two
timing nature two photographs of
Godzilla Footprints taken in different
eras Monarch equipment from two
different eras two shots of San
Francisco and Tokyo with San Francisco's
Trans America pyramid and Japan's Tokyo
Tower at the center of their respective
cities two keys to Hiroshi Randa file
cabinets in two different cities two
calendars centered around the February
and March of 1952 and 2015 a modern and
old look at the radiation Trail of the
flying mudo from episode 2 a shot of
that same mudo flying over a modern and
past version of the same city two
newspapers from San Francisco and Tokyo
detailing the 2014 San Francisco attack
from the 2014 Godzilla movie a monarch
agent in a gas mask with Tokyo's Rainbow
Bridge on the left side of his face and
San Francisco's Golden Gate Bridge on
the right side of his face two Godzilla
evacuation signs from California and
Japan and two mut warning signs from
both Russia and America like I truly
love this opening sequence because this
theme of dualities is represented in the
very cinematography of the show itself
like the shots of this show have been
purposely framed with dualities in mind
like how Katie and canaro are often
placed on two opposite halves of the
screen to represent their father's two
families and how researcher Koo Randa is
placed in the middle of Bill Randa and
Lee Shaw to represent the opposing
Natures of the two men that have a deep
affection for her and how the two black
and white flower pictures in kintaro's
family living room have inverted colors
or even how one side of this Frame here
has a Japanese restaurant with Japanese
text while the restaurant on the right
side here has English text with more
American style offerings to symbolize
the story's overall split between Tokyo
and San Francisco like there is a lot of
intention with the way a lot of these
shots in the show have been filmed and I
love it so much and I can't wait to see
how this theme of dualities is going to
play out in the overall monster
narrative but anyways as the episode
starts we see that Kate Randa lands in
Japan on April 1st 2015 April Fool's Day
one whole year after the devastating
Godzilla Event in San Francisco but
later on in the episode Kate is revealed
to have been part of the Convoy of
school buses crossing the Golden Gate
Bridge right before Godzilla arrived and
you can sort of see her school bus
stopped in front of the destroyed bridge
in the 2014 Godzilla movie Behind
another school bus that managed to get
on the other side I like how the costume
designers had Kate be the only person in
the airport wearing pink to let Kate
Stand Out amongst the rest of the
Travelers that are primarily wearing
either white black or blue but anyways
as Kate grabs a taxi we can see her
exiting Terminal 2 of the haneda Tokyo
International Airport then the taxi
drives her down Tokyo's Rainbow Bridge
from the opening sequence as the text
Tokyo 2015 pops up on the screen and as
the taxi drives into the city you can
see images of Godzilla graffitied with a
red no symbol around him showing Tokyo's
past history and Trauma with Godzilla
himself not sure what these signs are
actually going to achieve though because
there is very little chance that
Godzilla is going to whip out his
reading glasses to read and adhere to a
no Godzilla's allowed sign but hey
whatever makes the people of Tokyo feel
safe right but anyways I found it
hilarious when the taxi driver said the
San Francisco attacks were staged with
CGI because it's sort of a meta
commentary on how the Godzilla property
has advanced over the years in cinema
from the days of a man in a Godzilla
costume terrorizing a scale model of
Tokyo and the taxi driver having a
monster conspiracy podcast very much
reminds me of Bernie Hayes's Titan truth
podcast from Godzilla versus Kong but
anyways after Katie meets the other half
of her family for the first time the
show sends us back in time to 1959
Kazakhstan as a young Billy Randa played
by Anders home drives the gain to their
destination he wears the baseball hat of
the Negro League Kansas City monarchs a
team that could have potentially served
as inspiration for the name of the
Monarch organization before they adopted
the monarch butterfly Motif for the
organization's logo and later when the
Godzilla early warning system starts
blaring karo's mom calls Godzilla by his
original Japanese name Gojira a name
given to Godzilla as a result of a
mashing of the Japanese words gorira and
kujira meaning whale so Gojira literally
means gorilla whale which is quite
fitting considering that Godzilla is a
large aquatic monster that stands
upright like a gorilla but anyways after
traumatic flashback to the Golden Gate
Bridge Godzilla attack from the 2014
Godzilla movie she gets invited to her
father's Tokyo office and rips off his
version of the radiation Trail satellite
map that is introduced in episode 2 to
reveal a safe a safe that opens when
Kate enters the 5-digit code
77558 even though the safe is clearly
meant to be a 4digit code safe so either
this was a slight editing mistake on the
show's part or the safe only registered
the last four numbers 7 558 which Kate
chose based on karo's birth month of
July which is the 7th month Kate's Day
which appears to be on the 5ifth Cano's
mother's birth month of May and Kate's
mother's birthday on the 8th a prime
example of this Show's theme of
dualities at work however one particular
thing of note about after she puts in
the code is her reaction to it because
it seems like Kate is upset that both
her and her mom came second in this
combination possibly implying which
family Hiroshi loved more and later when
Kate and canaro had on over to May's
apartment Kate notices a poster of a
massive spider attacking a city that
canaro has apparently designed in the
past very much showing how much Godzilla
and the rise of Kaiju across the world
has started to affect art and media
however this piece of art might just
foreshadow a conflict that Katie and
canaro might have to face later on in
the season with the same creepy crawly
insect Kaiju that caused Grandma K Rand
to fall down a hole in the 1950s like
something tells me those insects are
still alive in 2015 but but anyways
later on when Collins runs to inform Tim
of May's accessing of classified Monarch
documents you can see that Tim has a map
of Japan on his wall pointing to his
specific interest in the Kaiju Godzilla
and as May is looking over all that data
with Kate and canaro we can see a
picture of what appears to be Wyatt
Russell's Young Lee Shaw holding a
helmet while wearing a uniform next to
three other people doing the same thing
with all four of them standing in front
of a large tank with the Monarch symbol
on it but that comes right before we see
the image of the large batl looking
Kaiju that will end up meeting at the
end of episode 2 that bill Lee and Kate
barely escaped from followed by images
of a giant piece of technology shaped
like a ball with a ton of wiring coming
out of it very much looking like an
early atomic bomb one of the skull
crawlers from Skull Island the USS Lon
that bill Randa survived on an elevated
atomic bomb and of course finally a
picture of Bigfoot confirming Bigfoot's
existence in legendaries monsterverse if
we do not get a Bigfoot versus Kong
movie at some point what is even even
the point of the Cinematic Universe I
mean seriously but anyways right after
this we get a flashback to the last time
Kate saw her father 5 days after
Godzilla's attack on San Francisco but
what's so strange about this moment is
how damn fast this dude got to Kate's
location as soon as she gave it to him
like what the hell was going on there
did Monarch invent some type of
teleportation device that we don't know
about like that was abnormally fast like
I truly wonder if we're going to get
some type of explanation for that moment
to the Future because I would very much
like to have one please like that
doesn't make any sense but anyway after
this Kate canaro and may find a picture
of ko standing in a giant godzilla
footprint before we get a flashback of
what looks like KO falling to her death
after being covered by a bunch of baby
Kaiju insects on a high rope however
there is a slight chance here that this
could be a misdirect as all of those
insects covering her body could have
shielded KO from the impact of the fall
and since it seems that these insects
were not really interested in biting KO
for food I wouldn't be surprised if we
learned that KO survived the fall and
became an accidental mother to all of
these babies who could have possibly
imprinted onto her due to Kate being the
first motherly face that they saw but
that's just a wild theory for now KO is
dead until the story says otherwise but
anyways moving on to episode 2 we get a
flashback to Young Lee Shaw's time in
the service in the Philippines Circa
1952 where we learn a little bit more of
Shaw's personality specifically how he's
a good-hearted soldier who cannot abide
by bullies a character type that Wyatt
Russell knows well while playing the
wannabe Captain America John Walker in
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Lee's
disdain for bullies seems to carry into
his older life when we see Kurt Russell
Shaw cut off his ankle bracelet as a
middle finger to the Monarch bullies
keeping him under close watch the bar
fight that the young leaw engaged in
apparently happened in a bar called the
bamb Bang Bar in the Luzon region of the
Philippines and right before they take
that fight outside you can see a poster
for a boxing match on that wall which I
thought was a fun way to joke about the
fight actually happening on screen with
the power of cinematography and while
Colonel Pucket is assigning sha to his
escort Mission you can see a framed
picture of US president Harry Truman
behind him as well as the Filipino flag
and later as Sha and Koo arrived to
their destination the song Hound Dog by
Big Mama Thorton plays on the radio
however though that song was recorded in
1952 it wouldn't be released until a
year after in 1953 so technically those
two should not be listening to that song
at all but hey they also shouldn't be
chasing radioactive monsters who will
either swish them or give them cancer so
I guess Koo really can do whatever she
wants she's a bad and you can't
kill her unless you're a bunch of baby
Kaiju insects then you could probably
kill her but anyways after the intro we
see a Sleepless canaro ditch his regular
work routine to head to his dad's office
and when he does he looks at the family
photos Hiroshi kept on his desk
including a family picture to Disneyland
as the Cinderella Castle can be seen
behind them and since Disneyland is
located in California that trip could
have possibly been a trip that hero she
went to go visit Kate's family on the
side then after canaro violently pushes
those pictures to the side he eventually
unlocks his father's secret cabinet to
find some old Monarch files files that
include a lot of Lee Shaw's military
documentation on the left side of the
first folder we can see a picture of a
young Leland Lafayette sha III next to
his military ID that reveals that his
birthday is on August 3rd 1924 making
Lee around 28 years old when he first
meets KO in 1952 and an impressive 91
years old when he beats Kate and canaro
in 2015 I generally hope that I am
healthy enough to run from a sketchy
government Affiliated Monster hunting
organization when I'm 91 because God
dang I can't even do it at 31 but
anyways under that military ID and
photograph is a letter from the US Army
reprimanding Shaw for his act of
violence in that bar in the Philippines
noting that Shaw's continuous lack of
discipline and inability to keep his
emotions in check is what led him to
being confined and losing 2/3 of his
paycheck for three whole months and we
also know that Shaw grew up with his
mother at 6 Main Street in Tulsa
Oklahoma by the time he had enlisted in
the military implying that Lee's mother
might have left their father because of
his alcoholism when canaro opens the
next folder we see Shaw's license on the
left page but under that we can see a
hotel room receipt for a room 440
reserved under the name no Dean or
possibly even naen then on the other
side of the folder we see a brochure and
welcome letter for the Futaba Resting
Home social Corporation facility that
canaro brings Kate and may to towards
the end of episode 2 the word Futaba
actually means Twins or the number two
which is this Show's subtle way of
continuing that theme of dualities and
when we get a flashback scene to 1952 as
KO and Lee are surprised by Bill Randa
in the Philippines notice how Lee Shaw's
finger is on the trigger as he points
his gun to the head of an unarmed man
like that is insanely irresponsible gun
etiquette as gun triggers are extremely
sensitive however considering Lee Shaw's
military file that dude has a little bit
of history with not thinking things
through while on the job but anyways
popping Back to the Future when canaro
first gets back home after failing to
get his father's files back from a very
curious may he puts on his slippers
featuring a black samurai and a white
Samurai another element of Duality
cinematography the clothes that canaro
and his mother wear in that scene as
they rip up old family photos seem to
Echo these two Samurai as Cano's
incredibly kind bright and warm mother
Amo wears white while the angry and
brooding canaro wears black and they rip
up black and white photos in front of
those framed black and white flowers
with inverted colors to symbolize how
canaro and his mother compliment each
other and form their whole true family
because they are all each other have
always needed like there is Hardcore
yin-yang type symbolism in that moment
for sure but shifting back to the 1950s
Bill and KO make their way to the USS
Lon the same ship the older John Goodman
Bill Randa references to Samuel L
Jackson's Preston Packard at gunpoint 21
years later in Kong Skull Island echoing
what his young self tells Koo in this
episode Bill Randa was serving in the
Navy when a Kaiju attacked his ship
killing everyone aboard but him and ever
since then Bill Randa has been on the
hunt to prove that mutos exist and that
they are very dangerous and as Bill
Randa goes through his old chest full of
personal items you can see a baseball
mitt with a baseball inside along with
the Monarch's baseball hat that we see
Bill wearing a couple of years in the
future kind of hilarious how the
baseball is still neatly placed in the
center of the mitt when the ship
literally got tossed thousands of miles
from where the loton was initially
attacked and later when May and Kate
start their Journey on the run from
Monarch's intimidating Tim Kate
references the born identity when
referring to may as Jason Bourne for
having a bag full of passports and rolls
of money then after this they run into
canaro on the street who reveals that he
is on the run as well and during this
moment the street number 6116 can be
seen placed in between both canaro and
Kate which also again contributes to
that Duality theme considering that the
number 6116 is a symmetrical palindrome
and finally at the very end of the
episode the 1950s gang finally runs into
that Dragon of aiju responsible for all
those Sky radiation trails and as it
goes to eat those three humans you can
see the same disgusting goopy saliva
that Kate and Bill saw all over the boat
definitely implying that the USS ltin is
this creature's new home but I'm very
curious why this creature did not choose
to eat the dead bodies on the boat I
wonder if this monster was just trying
to like lick the radiation off of these
people and wasn't really interested in
eating them for sustance but that is it
for this breakdown of episodes 1 and two
of Monarch Legacy of monsters thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter or Instagram or wherever I am on
the internet if you guys want to see me
post some weird but most
importantly don't forget to follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube because we got
some really great stuff for you guys on
the regula but yes you guys are great I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time bye